level that you never gonna get back
please always push it up to the brain
free never expect your respect back
British reach the keys you'll be tight
[Music]
picking up after the Joker has just
committed suicide while battling Batman
Dark Knight Returns took fall focuses
primarily on the divisions between the
left and right not the directions you
Muppet the story builds up - and focuses
on the eventual battle between Batman
and Superman throughout the story
Batman's come to represent that the
public can be trusted
to do the right thing in the end a
liberal mentality where is Superman sort
of more regimented and believes that any
male that sticks up should be hammered
down a Republican mentality the Blue Boy
Scout even drops Lions light isn't this
a school night and once it's playful
last it represents order in America as a
whole we're supposed to dislike Superman
and align ourselves with the Dark Knight
but both sides have their merits and
criticisms making it for a really good
in that battle of morals and physicality
it's a great analysis of modern-day
politics barely making it through his
ordeal escaping from the police
Batman feels like he's on his last leg
Gotham City soon follows suit the wall
that has slowly built up in the subplot
to this point comes to full fruition
when Russia launched a nuclear missile
at corto Maltese Superman belly
intercepting the missile allows it to
detonate over the seas
however the EMP caused by the blast
knocks all electrical equipment out and
Gotham while Superman recovers in a
scene that clearly inspired Batman V
Superman we see Gotham become a lawless
no-man's land
if you've ever beaten Magaluf imagine
now 3:00 in the morning everyone running
through the streets pissing on
everything vomiting everywhere fighting
one another having sex on a park bench
hell they'll heard mega loves all right
if you go in September it's basically
like that in Gotham freeway being known
for its
reputation it seems like Gotham City
doesn't have a chance of even making it
through the night that's where woody
Batman comes in gallantly riding on
horseback
Batman returns to Gotham bringing law
and order with him we are given the
first-person perspective of how
terrifying the events would be these
would later be realized in the terrorist
attacks on 9/11 and it's phenomenal to
see how this situation would be handled
should superheroes exist being more
relevant today than it was in 1986 I
really got the impression that Mello was
a forward thinker in this segment about
restoring Gotham whilst the rest of the
eastern seaboard descends into chaos
really elevates the stature of the Caped
Crusader Batman represents order however
it's an unorthodox order a symbol of an
establishment and it becomes a political
embarrassment because of it the
president decides that Batman's went too
far Superman who knows Batman will never
allow himself to be brought in alive
decide there's only one way to do it
you'll never take me alive copper to me
from this perspective it seems like
Superman always wanted an excuse to take
that man down
you get hints towards there being no
superheroes anymore and Superman being
the cause of that and Superman is pretty
much primarily users and Lackey a
deterrent to stop other countries from
attacking America he's brought in to
handle things that the president may
want distance himself from politically
Batman's a complete affront to this
that's why so dangerous once the people
begin to question the authorities there
could be a revolution Superman is here
to keep order and make sure everyone
stays in line Batman now out that line
let's go bring them back in
when kids weren't whispering in your ear
and running off giggling the playground
was a place where you would debate who
would win in a fight Batman or Superman
it was also where you wore your hood
over your head and pretended to be
Batman whilst your little loser made the
little dip kid it pretended to be Robin
that kid grew up to be CEO of a
multi-million pound company well it's
you scrape money together to read comics
he attend of sweet corn to eat BT this
would be a falling Christmas but I
digress
but never was a clear answer to that
question till 1986 Frank Miller dared to
have the two giants of comics face-off
against each other and it was a
momentous battle
Bruce wails on Superman threw out
hitting him with procedural attacks from
every angle he uses missiles to
Batmobile electronics and sonic waves to
impact the heroes sensors on every level
it's completely tactical and speaks
volumes to how prepared Batman is for
every eventualities the helmet makes him
deaf to Superman's pleas removing any
possibility of doubt I wish this was
something that hadn't been used in
Batman V Superman as it would have made
sense as to why cop couldn't reason with
the Dark Knight well know that they
didn't put much thought into that final
battle Oh with the help of Green Arrow
Batman uses kryptonite against the Man
of Steel beating on him until cardiac
arrest takes over his body and he dies
at the scene mirroring this Alfred to
passes away destroying Wayne Manor in
the process the fat is dead the legacy
is over so the world thinks fake news
that impression was crap pins out Batman
plan to fake his own death removing
himself from the limelight so that he
could once again operate in the shadows
at the funeral clock gears him but like
good ol America he lets him off it
allows Superman to be the good guy in
the end
realizing that he will never bet Bruce
Bowie
but as
he stays out his way he's okay with that
we end on Bruce rebuilding the cave with
the mutant gang realizing that this will
be a good life The Dark Knight Returns
is the perfect send-off for Bruce Wayne
it features heavy political subtext as
well as a gigantic showdown between
Batman and Superman to of comics most
iconic characters enveloped within this
book is a well written and crafted story
and we see the initial thoughts of it
come to full fruition here in the end
it's a perfect way to end his career no
matter how many times I read it this
chapter always blows me away it's a
momentous occasion that really nails
down the intricacies and differences
between Batman and Superman 'he's way of
thinking which makes them both such
interesting characters standing tall is
one of the greatest send-offs
ever no choice but to give this issue a
perfect 10 out of 10 so that concludes
my Dark Knight Returns review and
in-depth analysis brilliant from start
to finish this book absolutely deserves
to be on your bookshelf it would go on
to influence Batman comics for the next
thirty years and few of those comics
have managed to hold a candle to this
it's rare to find such a gripping read
and I urge those who haven't checked it
out to definitely pick it up adapted the
movies games animated films everything
really is the quintessential tale of the
Caped Crusader and I just I'm head over
heels with it after having reviewed all
four chapters weighing them all up as
one I decided to mark this story overall
as a 9.5 out of 10 it's just a brilliant
journey and you should definitely pick
it up so thanks very much for checking
out my Dark Knight Returns review it's
been a long time coming and it's took a
long time to get there so I appreciate
everyone who's watched it week by week
make sure you subscribe my child because
next time I'm doing the Dark Knight
strikes again with Buffy it's not gonna
be reviewed as highly but I don't know
why and then after that I'm gonna review
the Dark Knight 3 the master race it's
cut it's cure it's finally here so make
sure you check that out too
very much for taking the time to watch
everything I really appreciate it and I
love you take care peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]